Je t'ai sous-estimé Peter, est-ce que je sais que tu as
l'air d'avoir de la concurrence,
nous avons commencé à avoir des visiteurs
dans leur univers, ils meurent tous en combattant
Spider-Man, je suis désolé gamin ouais moi
aussi, non, il doit y
avoir une autre victoire, il n'y a pas
quoi  il se passe qu'ils commencent à
arriver, je ne peux pas l'arrêter,
Spider-Man ne rentre pas chez lui exclusivement dans les
cinémas le 17 décembre,
tu n'es pas Peter Parker, je suis tellement confus
en ce moment, ce sort que tu as
acheté a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers
le multivers est réel,
ils meurent tous en combattant Spider-Man, il
doit y avoir un autre moyen, ils ne
constituent pas un danger pour notre univers,
tout est de ma faute, je ne peux pas sauver
tout le monde.
Spider-Man, pas de chemin à la maison, au cinéma le
17 décembre.  depuis que j'ai été mordu par
cette araignée,
je n'ai eu qu'une semaine où ma vie m'a
semblé normale, c'est quand tu as découvert que
Peter
ce sort que tu avais bâclé a commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers,
ce qui se passe, ils commencent à
traverser  et je ne peux pas l'empêcher de rentrer à
la maison quand tu
penses, hé, je suis sur le point de faire quelque chose
qui pourrait briser l'univers, dirige-le par
nous la prochaine fois dans les salles le 17 décembre,
c'est Peter, laisse un message ouais Peter
ça  est heureux
qui sont ces gars, hein,
si les gars ont fait de la boue, qu'est-ce qui se passe,
rappelez-moi
quand j'ai arrêté ce sort, nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous les
univers, le
multivers est réel, c'est
qu'un dinosaure est
en salles le 17 décembre,
vous